i'm thinking of the time remember when
we were at k rock gary and you went on
that cruise and they got to see the red
hot chili peppers was that it was that
the right thing we were on a cruise we
were um up in uh the north pole wow
clear your throat gary go ahead
i'm good no it sounds like you have a
little phlegm in there
there okay good i think i feel fine you
do all right okay
um we stayed in the area we stayed on a
russian ice cutter then we took a
helicopter
to the actual magnetic north pole which
i think people like pay a lot of money
to just get out put a flag down to say
they were at the top of the world
magnetic north pole what the [ __ ] are
you talking about that's straight at the
top of the world why do you call it
magnetic north pole that's what they
kept saying that's what they kept saying
i just but why did you say
like there must be a north pole and a
magnetic north pole and you're not
really on the north pole like you're
near the north pole would you go to the
magnetic north pole you're really on the
north pole
gary you were you were on the magnetic
north pole not the real north pole i
don't know where i was so close
i have no idea
the red hot chili pepper show was on an
army base i think it was a hundred
people and it was i mean it was it was
tiny they probably got paid a fortune
you know and they had to go to the north
pole to do it it's not like they walked
out of their house and they performed
for 100 people they didn't even go to
the north pole they went to the magnetic
north pole whatever the [ __ ] that is
that's what they kept telling us
you know gary your teeth is so big did
the magnets at the north pole mess with
your fillings like did they start flying
out no everything was fine
i don't like that gary says magnetic
north pole like he's some sort of expert
he didn't even know what it is i know he
doesn't know where he was he doesn't
know why he was
i'm not bragging about it i'm telling
you that's where they told us
you said you were at the magnetic north
pole but that's where i was
you were at the north pole to say the
north pole i remember when we flew we
went above something that they called
the tree line
and it's just like there's it's like
literally you can see from the plane
it's just like green stuff just stops
growing uh oh there's the green line oh
i better tell the ball
uh-oh hope we make it to the red hot
chili peppers show gary
look both no more green
both one minute i was looking at green
and the next minute i wasn't looking at
anything i was like that's what it is
yeah i said
i'm a world traveler
uh oh
can't wait till we get to that magnetic
north pole
i love magnetic
anything it's a real place the north
magnetic pole it's a real place no
magnetic north pole
i feel like
bowie magellan did you know that the
only green i saw after the tree line was
the green on my teeth
so that would come in like a [ __ ]
haymaker you saw it like you saw the
tree line
by the way there is four magnetic north
poles could you guess which one i was at
hey fred if you can break character for
a minute you did you know there was a
magnetic north pole you probably knew
that i did know there was a magnetic
north pole yeah yeah and
it's very unclear as to where it is
because apparently with the earth it
shifts
it's moving
they say it's moving fast everyone will
be excited to know gary audiobook is on
the phone and wants to share his story
with us about the magnetic north pole go
ahead gary audiobook this is my list of
the most amazing things that i've got to
do that i thought i would never do
because i was involved with the show so
number one seeing the red hot chili
peppers play on the north pole got
invited to uh one of those gigs where
they did it was from magnetic noise my
wife and i went we were on a russian ice
cutter and going by icebergs and
everything and then we went to the red
hot chili peppers with 150 people it was
great wow
thanks guy gary audiobook
why in your book did you say north pole
and here you explain magnetic north pole
uh i don't know howard maybe because i
was just trying to be more precise for
you
all right
here i'll read from this science book
the earth is one big magnet the magnetic
north pole is also known as the north
dip pole
it moves miles every year
yeah who gives a [ __ ] i feel like i'm
back in school they had to go find it
howard they were like are we there yet
nope nope nope it moved